[Music]
first 30 years there's been this legend
that Atari buried millions of unsold
copies of its infamous video game flop
ET the extra-terrestrial in the New
Mexico desert it was such a flop but
apparently instead just destroying them
they buried them in the desert of New
Mexico this was a big rumor among gaming
people for a long time a crew dug up the
buried ET video game cartridges yes yeah
hey you think just throw them out they
were so ashamed of his game och Tory
drove them by the truckload into the
desert and buried them well now they've
been dug up and here's the crazy part
they kept digging turns out Atari buried
other terrible video games that were
based on movies yeah audience audience
cheering the premise yeah there were
other terrible video games based on
movies for example Rock III they found
the rock III game which really isn't
good
yeah there's bean John Malkovich that's
just not a good leave nothing good
there's woody happens hannah and her
sisters yeah
and finally I expected more from Fight
Club I really did
I thought fight club would be a better
game
[Applause]